why are you here
i am here because my ex-husband
is suing me
for an op-ed i wrote
and how do you feel about that
i
i
struggle to have the words
i struggle to find the words to describe
how painful this is
this is horrible
for me to sit here
for
weeks and
relive everything so we were secretly
dating and then
you know it was it was it was beautiful
it was um
i
felt like
this man
knew me and saw me in a way that no one
else had
i felt he understood me i felt he
understood
where i came from i i felt like
i felt that like when i was around
johnny i felt like the most beautiful
person in the world do you remember the
first time that he physically hit you
yes please tell the jury about it
it was so
it's seemingly so stupid so and like
insignificant
i will never forget it
i changed
it changed my life i was
sitting on the couch
and we were talking we were having a
like a normal conversation you know just
there was no fighting no argument
nothing
and um
he was drinking and
um i didn't realize at the time but i
think he was using cocaine because it
was like there was a jar a jar
of cocaine out on the table i realized
that sounds weird but it was like
an actual vintage jar of it
but i didn't see him use at the time so
i didn't really factor that in i just
you know he's drinking and we're talking
and it's there's music playing and he's
smoking cigarettes and we're sitting
next to each other on the couch
and i asked him about the tattoo he has
on his arm
and to me it just looked like
black marks like i didn't know i didn't
know what it said it just looked like
muddled faded tattoo that was hard to
read
and i said what is it what does it say
and he
um said it says wino
it says wino and i um
i didn't see that i thought he was
joking
uh because it didn't look like it said
that at all and i laughed
it was that simple
um i just laughed because i thought he
was joking
and slap me across the face
and i laughed
i laugh
because i
i didn't know what else
to do i thought
this must be a joke
this must be a joke
because i'm
i didn't know what was going on
i just stared at him
kind of laughing still
thinking
that he was going to start laughing too
to tell me it was a joke but he didn't
please describe for the jury
some of the cycles you had with mr depp
through 2012.
so
in 2012 the violence was
pretty
you know relative to what it became
pretty
you know slapping uh backhanding well it
went from
it went from this eggshell kind of
you're walking on eggshells nothing
you're doing is
kind of right but you don't know what
you're doing wrong
uh and then i was doing something wrong
clearly but they were it was unclear
within the scope of an argument what i
was defending myself against so it would
shift from
a rumor he had heard that i was with um
my a friend or i had been photographed
standing too close to a male person
that was a person i'd have a and i had
had something with and i was lying to
him about and the
would be egg it would be eggshells
accusations accusations and then he
would explode
um it started with throwing things um
destroying the property and screaming at
me i remember
the screaming at me was
the worst because i kind of always felt
like i had done
you know i had to defend myself i had to
tell him i so he didn't think these
things were true and sometimes
you know i he would shift accusations
while i'm trying to dispel one
accusation he'd start another one and
um
nothing i could do to calm him down it
seemed like you i'd walk away and that
would make it worse
um i remember he
in my apartment in orange it would he
would grab me by the hair or he'd grab
me by the arm face pull me into him
scream at me that way he'd smash things
around me then he would smash things
very close to me
and then he would just hit me and it
started with
slapping um and it got
to be like repetitive slaps where he'd
hold me
in a position and slap me multiple times
um in a row
uh
then it would be
you know eventually i later would either
push him off of me or i tried to hit his
hands away from me i tried it not in
2012 so much at that time i was mostly
my defense was
i'd go some other place like i don't
know how i don't know how to describe
that and then the month got
really crazy from that point on it was
um
a bit of
um
a revolving door of accusations uh he
was accusing me of having affairs with
um
well frankly just one person i hadn't i
was an acquaintance i had an
acquaintance with somebody and he was
accusing me of
of um of being with them and then it was
accusing me of being with my friend the
one i had seen in spain
uh
i i'm you know in these kind of
arguments nothing i do is working i've
walking out of the room
is me leaving him walking away from me
you know hey where are you going i'm
talking to you
that it
it went from that to
um
pulling me in by by my arm
still shouting at the
about the accusations um i'm trying to
defeat defuse the situation by trying to
tell him i'm not sleeping with this
person and i'm not sleeping with that
person and it was
kind of as soon as it seemed as though i
had convinced him of one
there was somebody else he was sure i
was sleeping with um and
he it was a revolving door at that time
a painting i had hanging on the wall
done by my ex who's a artist
that was one day he
he was convinced that that was proof i
was sleeping with her or having an
affair with her and is this a picture
that you took of yourself in march of
2013 i did you're going to move the
admission of defendants exhibit 178
any objection no objection all right 170
a in evidence you can publish the
picture thank you
and how did you sustain that bruise
amber
um
i was
i had thrown a um
why
johnny slapped me i walked away from him
and that made it worse
we got into like a
shouting match
and he kind of did this thing with his
body where i could tell he was going to
hit me again
um i picked up um like a
i remember it kind of like a um
like a little pop not a pot but um like
a base
and uh i i remember
i got away
from him enough as he reels back i threw
it in his direction
and actually managed to get away before
he got
before he got me
he grabbed me by the arm
and he kind of just held me on the floor
screaming at me
um
i don't know how many times he hit me in
the face but
i i remember being on the floor in my
apartment
and i'm just
i remember thinking
how could this happen to me again